hey everybody this is a palace which I
made in planet coaster as a little
building experiment as we go into alpha
3 and in the rest of this video I'll
pretty much show the process of making
this building and time-lapse and I'll
have a few clips at the end of this
video to show off what it actually looks
like but before we get into that I'm
gonna have to build the building first
of course so let's jump into it now the
first thing that I wanted to do which is
already very unconventional is make the
textures for the walls
and one thing that I really have to say
about this building is that it's a sort
of unique experiment in the sense that I
wanted to make every single parts of the
building custom now obviously for this
wall there isn't really a wall in the
game which has these very large white
bricks textures that you see in many
classical buildings so I had to make it
myself but the same goes for just about
everything in the building all of the
walls all of the windows and the roofs
are all going to be custom made and I
will be using some of the in-game wall
and roof pieces to make them but I want
actually use them for what they're
intended for because the in-game pieces
just don't really have the theme that
I'm looking for in this case which is a
bit vague it's a bit of a general
classic or eclectic theme I mostly just
started out without a plan but with a
bunch of inspiration from some beautiful
palaces that I found in Bucharest a
really big inspiration is actually the
crassula school palace but aside from
that I didn't really have any kind of
plan for this shape or details of this
building so you'll see that change a bit
basically what I started with is just
make the separate elements that I wanted
to use for this building so over here as
well I'm just making some roofs wanted
to get some very steep black roofs
because you haven't really seen them so
far in planet coaster but they would be
what goes pretty well with very white
lights walls that I have here and on top
of that just have a quick decoration
I also ended up making this corner piece
which is a bit diagonally chai ended up
not using because it's doesn't really
fit the straight walls that I have so
yeah you can really see I'm making the
elements first and only after then I
actually decide what I'm gonna do with
them and how I'm gonna make it look so I
eventually ended up scrapping that
diagonal roof piece but I did end up
using the top of that to make a new roof
piece which is actually square and which
should fit what the wall of the building
is actually like so I am making that
right here a bunch of things that I did
make for these buildings did take quite
a bit of planning because I did want to
make sure that everything fits correctly
and that nothing sticks out in an
awkward way so especially since I'm
using windows to get the black texture
there aren't really many black items in
the game yet it was a bit tricky now in
then to actually get these windows in
the position that I wanted to and not
have them stick through each other but
just by having that quick guide on the
octagonal line there I can just follow
the rest of what is the straight roof
and make the corner piece that way so
that's pretty much the corner elements
finished together with a straight roof
pieces they should be able to make just
about the entire roof section of the
building so as you can see here just
adding together the corner pieces and
the straight pieces to make the entire
roof I did change the building shape a
little bit as well at some points I'll
make the sides a bit shorter and make it
extend a bit less and also make it a
little bit lower but those are just very
small changes that you'll see happening
throughout this video I also wanted to
add some balustrade on top of the
building not because they're functional
but just to add a bit of extra
decoration on top of it and what I also
wanted to do which is something which I
haven't really tried before but which
actually works quite well one thing
which I have been looking for for quite
a while on this game is a really pointy
sort of decoration something that you
could put on top of a spire
or on top of a pillar which I haven't
really seen before but to insult that
the bottom part of these parrots is
actually quite good for that kind of
thing so I ended up using these
upside-down parrots - who make the
supports and the corner pieces for these
Bella straights make them look a bit
more interesting and make sure that
they're not floating anymore so that's
why the building is full of upside-down
parrots and another thing that I wanted
to get into is pilasters this building
does take quite a bit from classical
architecture and one thing that I wanted
to have over the entire building is
blessed errs on just about every major
grid points so I'm ending these all
around the building here there are just
blessed errs for the regular middle
parts of the building but I had to make
special ones for the corners here since
the building is on the grid and one
other thing that I wanted to do at the
front of the building which to not be
quite a headache is have a spire a part
that really comes forward but is also
the highest point of the building and
has a little bit more steep roofs than
the rest of it which meant that I would
have to make new roofs for it since
these are a bit more steep than the
other ones which was a bit of extra work
but in the end the only thing that I
really had to do is make a quarter tile
roof here put those together and then
just make sure to fill in the corners
later on so this really makes up the
spider it's really similar in the end I
feel 2 spires that you would find on
like second empire kind of architecture
which sounds really complicated and all
but it's religious what you would find
in many Disney main streets and that's
why I do think in the end the building
could actually fit quite well in any
kind of Disney park somewhere along the
Main Street or maybe even at the
entrance of the park but um yeah back to
topic a little bit I wanted to put the
same balustrade on top of this building
and the upside down parrots will
definitely make a comeback on it as well
and what you'll see me doing with many
of these details as well as get some of
these darker pieces into all of the
white pieces because nearly every single
part
the detailing of this building is made
out of those white pieces and just white
pieces over white pieces means that you
don't really see the details come out
that much and just to help the shadows
out a bit especially underneath some
pieces I wanted to add some of those
wooden and darker pieces to get a bit
more contrast and what's also a bit
special is I'm filling in these corners
with a roof that's actually not even
vertical but it's slightly more like
it's beyond vertical it's about an angle
of 100 degrees to make sure that the Sun
doesn't reflect awkwardly on it because
these are metal windows and it reflected
quite a bit more than I was wishing for
so I had to turn these a little bit
downward so that the Sun wouldn't
reflect on it and cause this weird
awkward white triangle and that's the
last thing I did on the roof moving on
we have to get into the windows of the
building and I wanted to start off with
the hardest part just get that out of
the way the dormers of the building
which we're a bit of an extra challenge
because they don't just sit on the roof
they also kind of extend over it and are
also placed over two tiles underneath
the roof so these are quite large
dormers with very large arched windows
and a nice little pointy roof on top of
them which we're quite simple to make
but I did need to keep in mind how I
make the rest of these buildings to make
sure that the dormers would actually fit
on top of the roof which took a bit of
measuring and making sure that I have
the same dimensions but that's pretty
much the simple roof bunch of windows on
top of it and an upside-down parrot to
make sure that I have that little
decoration on the top of the window and
a bit of wood to give them a bit of a
rustic feel and get some slides contrast
into it it was actually not my own idea
to add wood underneath the roofs that's
just something that you see on many
palaces in Romania which is also why I
figured if this building would be built
anywhere in real life it might probably
just be a romaine
palace somewhere in the city or just
outside of it with gardens around it and
by using this dormer and a bit of a
smart way by lowering its or actually
raising it and making a bit a bit higher
I could use the same dormer sort of
slightly different looking dormers and
I'll do that at some point in the future
as well but on the front of the building
on the big important spire that pretty
much is the biggest the most important
part of the building I did want to have
a slightly larger and more important
looking dormer it's a bit similar
actually I think to the round doorman on
the top tower of the Cinderella Castle
in Disneyland Paris with that sort of
round shape to it and it's a pretty
large dormer as well very large gloss
arc on top of it and that reduced finish
off the front spire quite nicely well
I'll get into some of these different
details around the building like topping
of the pilasters I didn't want to get
any fancy things on top of the plasters
usually you see some kind of top parts
with either leaves or like round parts
I'm not entirely sure what they're
actually called an English but um in
this case I didn't want to keep the
plasters quite simple and tekzilla'
since the rest of the building is
already quite busy and filled with
details and I didn't want to make every
single part of it just filter the brim
with details so they're quite simple
molesters but at least I wanted some
sort of thing to top them off and also
have a bit of bordering on the side
there and again a bit of wood in the
middle of those two parts to get a
slightly different texture not make the
building such a blinding sea of whites
and on the bottom of the building I
wanted to have a foundation wall kind of
like how on many classical buildings you
have the lower parts which are made out
of larger and rougher stones except in
this case it's really a sort of
sort of like a decoration foundation war
it's just a lower section with slightly
different textures and a bunch of
decorations on top of them to give it a
nicer look than just having the walls
sink into the ground straight away it's
also going to be where the building is
raised because I do want to have some
steps in front of the building so it's
gonna be a bit of a raised building the
rest of the building is going to sit on
top of that foundation wall now not
unimportant either the windows of this
building as a real palace should it's
gonna be filled with Windows that are
well decorated around all of the sides
around all of the size of the building
so I wanted to have two slightly
different windows one for the bottom
floor and one for the top floor the
bottom floor is slightly smaller and
just kind of sticks over the foundation
wall while the top floor is going to be
the big fancy window with in the future
also balconies all around the sides so
you'll see that come up and I'm using
some really strange elements here to
make the size of these windows since
there isn't really too much to actually
get these white borders around them but
I did want to have some slightly
classical looking windows so on the top
window you can really see those pillars
with the pillow tops and on top of that
the small round pediments as many
classical buildings would have and on
the bottom building it's just a square
sort of frame around it which just pops
up over the foundation wall and in
between them I wanted to leave some
space obviously since the balconies
underneath these windows are going to be
quite large so adding the balconies here
the foundation piece for the balcony is
the fountain piece which I believe is
supposed to be placed on top of the
octopus but in this case it just proved
to be a perfect little round balcony
thing I actually did use balconies for
the balcony fences but of course they
are made in a bit of a circle and I
wanted to overlap a couple of them since
they are like they have a really narrow
texture that you don't really notice
that much so just to bring that out a
bit more in May
them a bit darker they are two balconies
each time sort of layered over each
other to get a slightly thicker fence so
we have that in there and on the sides
of the building I didn't want to have
the same windows everywhere and in those
small nook and crannies where these
wouldn't really fit I needed to make
some slightly smaller windows so make
those very quickly they're not very well
decorated or anything but at least they
finish off the sides of the building
like that and that is basically most of
the building finished with just a couple
of finishing touches on the window in
the middle which is a copy of the top
windows on the rest of the building but
since the spire is a bit higher than the
rest of the building I needed to get a
window which was a bit taller as well
which does make it look a bit fancier -
so I'm added a slightly larger window
there and I'm also working on the door
here which is going to have some steps
in front of it and a very large avenue
going toward the centre of this palace
as you would have with many palaces and
the borders of the stairs kind of have
two purposes here for one they make the
stairs look a little bit more fancy but
also they're supposed to cover up how
not great I am at making stairs that
don't clip on all the edges so they kind
of keep the stairs in place and make
sure that they don't have bits sticking
out everywhere and also pretty important
I wanted to get some very fancy palaces
like lamps and it seems like the Bell
was actually perfect to get both a small
decoration underneath the lights and be
able to have four lights on one post to
make those lamp posts extra large and
alluring like you kind of want to have
in front of a palace so that is just
about the front section of the building
now I needed to copy over what I wanted
to do with the window on the front I
actually ended up ya not using the same
windows that I used before and the
reason for it was actually that it
turned out that those windows weren't
centered over here
I'm not sure if that's because the
windows iron centered actually remake
those a couple of times to make sure
that they seem perfectly in the center
of the spots but it might just be that
they aren't actually centered I'm not
really sure what was up with that
maybe I've also used the wrong pillars
on front of this building anyway I made
a new window just about in the same way
as all of the other windows so far and
add a bit more decoration on top of the
tower to finish that off as well
and I believe that is just about the
main building pretty much finished after
these couple of details over here - yeah
and that extra bit of topping - the
building itself oh yeah I forgot about
the foundation walls over here as well
I didn't want to entirely copy them
though since that would take a lot of
efforts and I was feeling really lazy
when I was doing this so that should
just feel that should just finish up the
foundation was quite nicely it's a very
small section anyway and it is sort of a
section that sticks out so I'm not
really too worried about it
now on to the last part of this video
and I didn't film all of it but
hopefully I did film the most important
part of it the garden around the castle
which is not or the palace I should say
which is not too big it's quite simple
as well but it's just something that I
wanted to make to give the building a
bit of context the building itself is
definitely what this is all about it's
not a video about a palace with its
castle but I didn't want to put it sort
of in its natural habitat if you will so
just to kind of get an idea of what this
would look like if it were actually a
palace inside some sort of Palace
Gardens for some sort of royalty summer
retreat
so very quickly made that sort of
improvisational layouts based on shapes
based on the symmetrical shapes that you
very often find in these kinds of things
I'm not a garden palace knowledgeable
person but this was more or less my idea
of what
would look like I suppose build hatches
around all of these squares and
different shapes that I had in between
the parts and at first I placed all of
these lanterns over here but then it
turned out that they were kind of
looking the view of the building which
isn't very good so I ended up making
some slightly smaller lanterns just to
get them inside the middle sort of Road
to make sure that I actually had lights
and some slightly fancy ones at that but
make sure that the lights weren't
actually blocking the view of the
building so I'm still using the light
lights on the side but in the middle
road definitely wanted to use the
smaller ones now on to what is going to
be most of the foliage of the gardens I
wanted to make a few sort of custom
bushes almost like the topiaries that
you find in many of these gardens I was
almost going to like make my own ones
because you can't kind of make your own
custom topiaries out of these if you put
them together and really smart and
creative ways but I wasn't really
feeling that so I just turn them into
slightly thicker versions than what they
actually are so I just did that for a
bit and at some borders around the road
to make that a bit more fancy added some
flowers there's gonna be a bunch of
flowers of course and a few more bushes
around the building it's just a building
in the middle of nowhere with no foliage
around it looks a bit boring and here
I'm just adding a couple more bushes
around these parameters of these marks
of area so you probably get the drill at
this point the basic approach to this
was really stupid and simple and just
winging it and funky sort of geometric
shapes into the road layouts and after
that proceed to fill in with all sorts
of funky little plants and that was
basically how I did it now we're almost
at the end of this time-lapse and I'll
leave you guys alone with the final
shots of the palace so I have to say
thank you guys for watching it's been
fun to make this thing even if it meant
that negatory is most definitely not
going to be finished in a way that I was
planning it but this was just something
I've really really wanted to try and
make before alpha-3 would come out thank
you guys for watching